SCP-173 it's one of the most iconic
anomalies ever contained by the SCP
Foundation this next snapping site 19
celebrity is known and feared by
everyone who works at the foundation
since being contained in 1993. its nubby
concrete hands metaphorically and quite
literally stained with the blood of
countless people but this mostly
immobile Oddity wasn't always a resident
of site 19 and the story of how exactly
it ended up there and more importantly
why is far more ridiculous insane and
downright terrifying than you could ever
imagine so buckle up SCP fans this is
the dramatic tale of how this homicidal
piece of Modern Art ended up at the SCP
foundation's largest containment site to
give you an idea of just how weird this
origin story is we're gonna have to leap
forward to the year of 2045. we know
what you're thinking isn't this a
prequel how can it take place in the
future sit tight folks it'll all makes
sense in the end site 91 is where we lay
our scene under the watchful eyes of
site director Dr James long a senior
researcher with level 4 security
clearance the second highest at the
foundation Dr long had given Decades of
devotion and his expertise to the
foundation he was a proud man who wore
his life of service to the containment
cause as a badge of honor after years of
dodging death while researching some of
the most dangerous anomalies that
site-91 had to offer he had ascended to
the rank of site director which
represented the culmination of his
life's work and in his new position of
power he'd only proved himself further
running a tight ship and reducing the
number of containment breaches across
the board nobody could say that Dr long
was an extremely talented at his job
which is why he was so confused when he
received an email from Alexandra Nala an
administrative assistant working
directly for the o5 council it was the
type of email that no site director ever
wanted to receive Dr was being told
backed with no input or oversight from
him the majority of site-91's anomalies
were going to be taken to an undisclosed
location for safer containment the list
contained nearly every meaningful
detainee contained on the site including
of course as cp-173 this particular
anomaly had been contained at the site
for 37 years after being delivered there
in 2008. Dr long had devised a perfect
method to minimize containment breaches
in that time creating a sprinkler system
within the chamber that washes away the
waste products produced by 173 reducing
the need for risky human contact but
that didn't matter despite Dr Long's
loyalty and efficacy in serving the SCP
Foundation the decision had already been
made with no chance of reversing it
according to Nala the motion to remove
most of site-91's anomalies had received
unanimous approval from the o5 council
and the operations for the transfer
would be commandeered by the department
of extra Universal affairs headed by
senior agent Sven Kish Dr long was both
upset and confused he was producing some
of the best results across the entire
foundation so why were they taking away
all of his anomalies did someone on the
yo 5 Council have it out for him Dr Long
replied to Nala asking if considering
how severe the relocation operation was
going to be whether he could get more
information on where the anomalies were
being moved to and why he felt that at
the very least he was owed some answers
on this Nala and her superiors didn't
feel quite the same way she replied that
Dr Long sadly didn't have the clearance
to know any of the operations
particulars this information was
reserved for those with level 5
clearance and members of the
multi-universal department all that Dr
Long needed to do was stay out of the
way and everything would be taken care
of for him but that wasn't enough for Dr
long he needed to know more he needed to
understand why this seemingly random
decision had been made realizing that
Nala and the o5 council were a dead end
as far as information was concerned he
instead reached out to the next best
thing senior agent Sven Kish the member
of the Department of extra Universal
Affairs who was spearheading the
relocation Mission Dr Long implored the
agent to give him extra information on
where all the site 91 anomalies were
being moved and why they were being
moved in the first place predictably he
was once again stonewalled being told
that any information regarding the
project was above his level of clear
appearance in a move that seemed
decidedly spiteful agent Kish signed off
by saying that he looked forward to
seeing Dr Long at site 91 and not long
after that he did agent Kish along with
a huge number of agents and task force
members from the multi-u Department
arrived on site bearing state-of-the-art
containment equipment an exasperated Dr
Long wasn't able to glean any more
information from this experience the
multi-u agents were ruthlessly efficient
transferring The Lion's Share of the
anomalies into temporary containment and
transporting them off-site within a few
hours by the time they were done Dr long
and his staff were left with one of the
most desolate and empty containment
sites on the foundation's books here was
Dr long with Decades of service and
climbing the organizational ladder only
to be left as a glorified babysitter for
a handful of low priority anomalous
items it all felt like a cruel joke
after several days of nothing happening
in the now incredibly uneventful site 91
aboard Dr Long reached out to a friend
of his researcher nurul shafiqe binte
Ahmad Ibrahim whom he called by the
nickname Shack to vent his frustrations
she commiserated sharing her sympathy
for his suddenly much less exciting
working conditions but saying that at
least the job should be a little less
lethal now Shaq didn't know it yet but
on this particular Point she was
terribly wrong Dr Long shared his theory
that perhaps some sites were being
Consolidated so the foundation could
save money and that this would lead to
layoffs Shaq essentially told him that
he was worrying too much the reality was
that Dr long had some very good reasons
to be worried his problem was that he
hadn't been worrying about the right
things in Foundation containment area
179 something awful was brewing as usual
gonze posted around
scp-2317 an old door containing a portal
to another world waited while Foundation
staff and d-classes performed the
standard procedure 220 Calabasas ritual
within they were dealing with one of the
most dangerous anomalies in the entire
universe but even then after Decades of
service one can be numb to such things
suddenly without warning the door opened
and a terrified Foundation researcher
tumbled out panting heavily eyes bulging
in existential horror he screamed the
words that he long hoped would never be
spoken in his or even his children's
lifetime it happened the chains have
broken the Devourer is free the sirens
sounded and an alert spread across the
entire Foundation database
scp-2317 is compromised
scp-2317-k the Devourer of Worlds is
free if the creature escapes area 179
and XK Class end of the world scenario
is basically assured so all efforts will
be taken to make sure that the creature
does not Escape at any cost and they
really did mean any cost the old wooden
door of scp-2317 splintered as an
immense scaly hands sprang forth and
caught a wave of Devastation throughout
the containment chamber guards were
dispatched in the hundreds with heavy
Weaponry to buy some time firing at the
Devourer a beast the size of a mountain
Rose from the ground staring at the
terrified humans below with its one
gigantic red eye it couldn't even feel
the bullets explosives or incendiarian
laser Weaponry being used on it the
monster just Shrugged it off and
murdered nearly all of its attackers
with one swipe of its claw in a final
desperate act hoping to kill or at least
slow down the Beast staff at area 179
made the ultimate sacrifice and
detonated the entire on-site nuclear
Arsenal the explosion disintegrated the
entire facility in an instant and
Unleashed a radioactive shock wave that
carried Destruction for miles but it
wasn't enough
scp-2317-k walked out of the mushroom
cloud without a scratch on it ready to
show the human world what real destruct
action mat at this point the battle was
already effectively lost but the
foundation refused to go down without a
fight they dispatched all available
mobile task forces including mobile Task
Force new 7 Hammer town a heavily armed
Battalion strength task force created to
combat the biggest and most extensive
threats imaginable and it wasn't even
just the foundation true existential
threats have a way of uniting people as
the GOC and even the chaos Insurgency
temporarily put aside their differences
to take the fight to the Devourer but
would any of it be enough barrages of
cruise missiles and icbms did nothing to
Halt the devourer's assault as it
rampaged destroying towns and cities at
first then regions then whole Nations
swarms of scrambled Jets and helicopters
were knocked out of the sky with casual
swipes the creature bulldozed over
Landscapes teeming with tanks and heavy
artillery Vehicles it snapped aircraft
carriers in half as it waited from Ocean
to Ocean systematically destroying
everything in its
even satellite mounted orbital cannons
and the heavy energy weapons of MTF tau5
also known as samsara did nothing to
phase the Devourer it was finally coming
to fruition the dreaded XK Class end of
the world scenario and none of the
foundation's expertise advanced
technology or Limitless resources could
do anything to stop it they aided in
evacuation efforts getting as many
people as they could out of Harm's Way
as the Devourer rampaged and destroyed
but even that was doing little more than
borrowing time eventually the Devourer
would destroy all of them there would be
nothing left and all Dr James long could
do was watch helplessly from an almost
empty site-91 waiting for the tide of
Destruction to reach him of course other
Foundation employees most prominently
senior agent Sven Kish and the multi-u
department had other concerns all they
needed to do was archive data for
extraction extraction to where you ask
seeing as the world seems to be at its
end here well Universe 7392 Epsilon blue
Lima otherwise known as our universe
Circa 1993 the foundation Works across
the Multiverse and an XK class under the
world scenario in one Universe really
isn't necessarily a problem in others on
orders of the o5 council agent Kish and
his men are charged with extracting data
and valuable anomalies like SCP-173 from
doomed universes o5 knew that Dr Long's
Universe Universe 5643 gamma orange
Delta was due for an apocalyptic visit
from the Devourer of Worlds any day now
that's why the multi-u team went in to
extract everything worth Saving Dr long
and the millions of other level 4 and
Below employees of that universe's
Foundation were never told of their
Impending Doom after all that sort of
thing could probably lead to unnecessary
stress and what they don't know won't
hurt them until of course it does in
1993 these anomalous doomed Universe
scps were divided amongst our universe
versus various applicable containment
sites
SCP-173 as you already know ended up in
site 19 but sadly for the people working
there all the actual data files on this
entries file Were Lost in Translation so
as far as they knew 173 was little more
than a big weird statue with apparently
dangerous properties upon first placing
it in its containment chamber in site 19
Euclid Wing Foundation Legend Dr bright
unaware of just what he had here
assigned Dr William Moto to begin
research on the entity he recommended
that the researcher bring two d-classes
for testing when Dr Moto was faced with
the anomalous entities blank file he
gave a sign began to write something in
its description box moved to site 19
1993 origin is as of yet unknown wasn't
that a Deloitte for little tale now we
know how SCP-173 made its way into site
19 and what our own universe may have to
look forward to in 2045
so remember if you ever see agent Sven
Kish planning a transfer of anomalies
out of your site maybe consider using
some of that PTO and maybe consider
Putting a down payment on a nice cozy
apocalypse bunker over in Iceland no of
other Tales you'd like to see us cover
let us know down in the comments below
the SCP Foundation specializes in
tracking down and containing anomalies
that are difficult to find and that
often will do anything they can to avoid
being found one anomaly in particular
hates being seen more than anything and
will punish anyone who looks at its face
with a horrific fate
scp-096 is a mysterious creature not
only because it destroys anyone who sees
what it truly looks like no one is
entirely certain where it came from what
exactly it is or why it reacts so
violently to being perceived there are
however several theories as to the Shy
Guy's origin and none of them are
particularly cheerful some suggest an
experiment gone wrong others believe it
to be the last remaining member of an
unknown species of mountain dwelling
humanoids well one theory about
scp-096's origin stands out as
particularly tragic in nature in this
story scp-096 was not always a
long-limbed pale Beast cowering in the
corner and hiding its face from the
world it was once an ordinary man like
anyone you might pass on the street he
was someone's son someone's friend a
person with hopes dreams and passions a
human being who through anomalous
circumstances Beyond his control was
made into a monster many years ago there
was a mountaineer named Jack all his
adult life he had been obsessed with
reaching higher and higher Peaks
climbing Every Mountain he could in
order to test his limits hit himself
against the power of nature and bask in
the sweet reward that was the view from
it began as a Spore a way to build up
strength while taking in incredible
natural beauty but over time as he
conquered increasingly difficult
challenges it became an obsession like
every Obsession eventually does climbing
mountains began to take over his life
driving everything else away he
struggled to hold down a job his
marriage fell apart and his
relationships to his friends and family
became increasingly distant and strained
still he couldn't bring himself to care
much he spent his alone time in the
wilderness or every so often embarking
on trips with other Mountaineers whether
he was going at it Solo or working with
others he was living for the climb over
the years he took on cerotore in
Argentina Diego in Switzerland and
Denali in Alaska he especially enjoyed
climbing an extreme cold waving the ice
and snow as he embarked on his climbs
the few fellow Mountaineers he kept up
with gave him the nickname Jack Frost
after years of refining his craft
building his strength he set his sights
on the highest mountain in the world his
personal white whale Mount Everest
itself it was one of the deadliest
climbs in the world with its staggering
height storms and Frozen graveyard of
Fallen climbers dotting the snowy
surface but he was determined he would
not join the ranks of the Fallen but
instead be one of the Victorious that
reached the top of Everest and came back
down in one piece he could feel it in
his bones Jack arrived in Nepal with a
pack full of climbing equipment the best
boots money could buy and layers upon
layers of clothing to keep himself warm
on the journey to the summit he lowered
his goggles over his eyes summoned his
courage and prepared for the incredibly
difficult climb the cold seeped into his
core the wind snipped at his face
numbing his nose and leeching through
his gloves and boots as he went but Jack
pressed on he welcomed the Cincinnati
station the bite of it it was a reminder
that he was still here that he was still
alive as long as he could feel the pain
he knew he was all right he knew that it
was when the cold faded away turned to
paradoxical feelings of warmth and
sleepiness that a mountaineer was truly
in trouble as he navigated the harsh
mountain landscape Jack occasionally let
his eyes drift off course taking in the
science around him he could see shocks
of blue green and red the distant bright
colors of boots jackets and hats
belonging to the Fallen climbers that
came before him those who collapse from
exhaustion who gave in to altitude
sickness or succumbed to the cold
Memento Mori he said softly to himself
these frozen bodies represented that
ever-present reminder of mortality of
death lurking just out of sight he would
not come for him though not today not on
this journey he wouldn't let it the
hours blurred together within the crunch
of the eyes beneath his boots the Dig of
climbing hooks into the Earth the tug of
his trusty ropes as he ascended ever
higher Jack came to a stop there was no
next step to tank nowhere higher that he
could go he had reached the summit the
white whale was captured and Everest was
his for the very first time he was truly
on top of the world now that he had made
it to the highest point there was the
all-important task of climbing back down
at this altitude he was still in the
death zone the place where human
acclimatization was impossible this was
the tricky part the point at which even
the most experienced of climbers might
get lost in the Euphoria of the
achievement and might let their
attention slip any mistake during his
dissent any misstep could be the thing
that cost him his life there was no room
for error and no time to waste just as
Jack prepared to make his descent he saw
a figure pulling itself over the ridge
from a distance it looked like a fellow
climber he noticed the Curious lack of
equipment and the way the person seemed
to be making their way up the mountain
with nothing but their hands but perhaps
they lost their pack or left it behind
for some reason the figure was dressed
in all white from their Hood to their
boots with a large pair of Black
Mountain goggles covering what little of
their face wasn't concealed by the hood
uncertain if the figure was in need of
assistance and surprised to see another
Soul on the mountain with him jack waved
at the figure everything okay he called
there was no response but the figure
turned to look at him at least he
thought it was looking at him he
couldn't see its eyes through the
goggles but he felt the distinct
sensation of it locking its gaze with
his just the same as soon as the figure
turned to look at him jack began to feel
strange the pain the sharp sensation of
the cold that he relied on to ground
himself and remember he was really here
began to blur around judges the feeling
softened melting away along with the
ache in his muscles the blurriness in
his eyes the dry mouth that had nagged
at him for hours he felt unbalanced
unmoored a ship with no anchor he
couldn't explain why but the sudden
relief from the cold made his chest
tightened with Primal Terror he did not
feel like one man encountering another
on the mountain he felt the way he had
years ago when he came face to face with
a mountain lion staring down a predator
and remembering all of a sudden that
humans do not naturally sit at the top
of the food chain this figure this thing
it was no man it was no person Jack
prepared to continue his descent to get
away from the strange Intruder as
quickly as possible but his feet would
not obey him his eyes cannot break
contact with the figure in white that
was slowly beginning to advance toward
him one slow step at a time it was in no
hurry it knew he was not going anywhere
anytime soon he trembled as the figure
grew closer its incrutable face hidden
beneath its hood and behind its goggles
he wished he could just see its face but
dreaded learning What secrets it was
hiding if only he could just unstick his
feet from the earth Break Free of this
spell that had fallen over him he could
Escape but no matter how much his
muscles strained how he gritted his
teeth with effort he couldn't get away
as the entity came closer the cold
snapped back into his body but something
was different it was heightened like
every icy Breeze and freezing wind
layered on top of itself hardening his
muscles to rock crystallizing the very
blood in his veins he felt as if his
fingers if he tried to wriggle them
would snap off and fall to the ground
his eyes thrummed in their sockets his
lungs stretched to hold on to each
breath as the cold constricted its fist
around his chest he opened his mouth to
speak but his voice died in his throat
coming out
Whisper of air now the thing was close
enough to touch him and whatever Force
had been holding him still and upright
released him it was as if he were a
marionette suspended in the air and the
Puppeteer released his strings at once
he crumpled to the snow-covered ground
in a heap his cheek pressed into the
Earth his eyes trained helplessly on the
still advancing figure his lip formed
the word please though he could not tell
exactly what he was begging for his life
his freedom a painless death perhaps he
struggled to push himself to his feet
but all the strength had gone out of his
limbs he could barely lift his arm let
alone handle the weight of his whole
body the thing shaped like a man was
right above him lowering down through
those opaque goggles he still could not
see its eyes but somehow he could feel
the way it was looking at him hatred was
radiating off of it disdain and pure
unadulterated malice then it tilted its
head to the side thoughtfully and Jack's
mind was overwhelmed with images he felt
the Phantom sensation of sunlight on his
skin and springy green grass beneath his
bare feet he could see clear as day in
his Mind's Eye a forest in the middle of
summer Dew drops sparkling on the Petals
of wildflowers blowing in a gentle sweet
Breeze then he felt sand between his
toes smelled the Sea Breeze felt the
comfort and contentment of a nap on the
beach it was not offering these things
to him but something like them something
like peace it was offering him a gift
but he didn't want it he couldn't take
it he was Jack Frost damn it he thrived
in the cold the hardship he didn't want
some warm sleepy Fade Out of existence
if he went out it would be on his terms
doing the thing he had dedicated his
life to if he were going to lose his
life he wouldn't roll over and just give
it up it would need to be pried from his
Frozen hands with every last bit of
strength he twisted his head away from
the entity's Gaze covering his face with
his hands it grabbed at him shaking his
shoulders trying to force him to uncover
his face and meet its gaze once more but
he didn't budge he wouldn't he couldn't
then he felt the energy shift as it
realized he had refused the gift that he
would not welcome the paradoxical
feelings of heat and security and slip
away as it was asking him to but it was
not a victory he swore he could hear a
voice in his mind saying very well
to be part of the mountain
I
make it so
the world went light as Jack's eyes
rolled back in his head his spine
curving back until it snapped his jaw
cracked and distended his arms and legs
stretched out long and twisted his body
contorted at unnatural angles as the
entity began to rearrange his very being
as the agony ripped through him snapping
his bones and tearing his muscles Jack
kept his face cradled in his hands he
remained in that position even as he
cried his voice hoarse as the pure fear
and pain overwhelmed his senses until he
forgot his own name forgot he was ever a
man at all when Jack was no more when
something else sat there in his place
pale and shivering body racked with sobs
the king of the mountain turned and left
him there alone with his misery still he
would not uncover his face he would not
let himself be vulnerable and would not
look up days later a group of
Mountaineers reached the summit of
Everest and spotted the hair careless
figure crouched in the snow weeping
softly are you all right one of them
asked the figure lifted its head slowly
and locked eyes with the strangers its
eyes widened in horror its mouth
stretched impossibly wide in a wordless
scream of rage and hurt and with nothing
human left in its mind or heart
scp-096 took its very first victim robed
figures with hidden faces stand over
seven young women tied up the robed
figures chant phrases both Arcane and
profane the leader amongst these dark
cultists clears his Wicked throat and
says Be not Afraid girls you are here
for something wonderful do we get seven
perfect children for the Scarlet King
how did we get here and more importantly
what happened afterward in the near
constant darkness that follows the Grim
but necessary work of the SCP Foundation
there is one bright light that can
always be counted on to keep hope alive
to bring a little sunshine into
everyone's days
scp-999 the Tickle Monster the sweet
simple creature does nothing but provide
an endless source of Joy hugging playing
and delighting and loving everything
around it but what if I told you that
this slimy little friend has hidden
depths a tragic history that seems
impossible to reconcile with the happy
playful being we all know and love how
could 999 the happiest SCP ever have a
sad backstory while it's one of the best
kept secrets at the foundation before we
get to that let's talk about a
foundation researcher and her brand new
job a new job that would make her privy
to some highly classified Foundation
Secrets Dr Izzy Collingwood was
delighted to wake up to a call informing
her that she had been appointed to one
of the most coveted positions at the SCP
Foundation after applying Crossing her
fingers and hoping for the best she had
been promoted to head researcher for
scp-999 what could be better than
attending to the kindest gentlest cutest
anomaly in Foundation custody gone were
the days of coming into work and
wondering if she'd leave in one piece no
more cleaning up toxic spills fighting
to contain killer creatures or fetching
cups of coffee for old doctors that
wouldn't give her so much as a thank you
years of hard work had paid off now she
could rest on her Laurels and do work
that she truly enjoyed there was just a
matter of some simple paperwork and she
would be ready to begin this extremely
welcome new chapter of her professional
life when she walked into her office to
get started on the paperwork something
unusual caught her eye there was a small
stack of files on her desk with a sticky
note attached to the front there were
just two words written on the note to
indicate what might await her inside the
folders the truth she scoffed at first
very funny guys she called out the door
but no one responded no one came forward
to take credit for the elaborate joke
maybe they were playing the long game or
maybe she couldn't be sure she sat down
flipping the first folder open it was
Untitled unlabeled just plain text on a
page she almost closed it after a brief
scan but the words the Scarlet King
jumped out at her she had worked at the
foundation long enough to hear that name
more than a few times often spoken in
hush tones as if merely speaking his
name would bring about some kind of
disaster as she dug deeper into the file
she realized just what she was looking
at the proposed origins of the Scarlet
King himself it was is a folkloric
explanation one her scientific mind
struggled to wrap around but she had
seen so many strange things over the
years things that defied all rational
explanation perhaps there was some truth
to be found in the myths the Scarlet
King had according to the file once been
an elder god born from the earliest days
of existence in the shadows of the tree
of knowledge he had devoured his
brothers and sisters growing stronger
with each one he consumed as his
strength increased so too did his
overwhelming pain and hate his deep
desire to destroy the tree of knowledge
and all living creatures he declared
himself the king of darkness and through
a series of horrific events took seven
unwilling brides and bound them to him
with magical seals each bride bore
Supernatural children powerful terrible
and monstrous the first bride actic had
only a few children those few were
skilled strategists exceptionally wise
in the ways of war the second bride was
alcohol overcome with constant Despair
and desolation her children conquered
with massive unthinking armies never
stated and never quelled the third bride
at a stop hated her sisters and all she
surveyed the fourth bride asiab took the
shape of a great Beast her children
followed in her Steed and were
invulnerable their thick hides
impenetrable by physical or magical
means the fifth bride was unhut blessed
with a strong mind and cursed with a
fragile body her children were gifted in
the ways of magic and Incredibly
destructive the sixth bride attilif
would not speak she kept to herself and
like her her children moved in silence
disguising themselves as whatever they
wished the seventh bride however was
different ahabat was her name the
smallest of the seven with an unbroken
Spirit she birthed Mighty Heroes that
she trained in secret in hopes that one
day they would overcome her family's
darkness and topple the king from his
throne all the while the Scarlet King
wages his Unholy war against all things
waiting for the day he can arrive in our
realm and unleash absolute destruction
Dr Collingwood shuttered as she finished
reading an undeniable chill passing over
her this definitely wasn't some kind of
prank or hazing ritual this was
something dark something real she held
secrets in her hands and she couldn't
stop reading them now she opened the
next folder it was a description of a
cult monitored and raided by the SCP
Foundation called the children of the
Scarlet King also known as group Mendes
during a 16-month investigation of the
anomalous religious group the
foundation's undercover operatives were
able to ascertain a great deal of
pertinent information on the group what
they found was troubling and of great
concern the group had ties to several
wealthy benefactors as well as links to
extremist paranormal groups their set of
beliefs was relatively simple and
disturbing they worshiped the Scarlet
King and were devoted to supporting him
in his battle to destroy the Earth and
all Life As We Knew It the faithful who
followed him in this task would be
rewarded handsomely with positions of
power in this new hellish World an
initial estimate put the cult's
membership at approximately 8 000
members a quarter of whom belonged to
the group's primary branch in Alabama
the reporting on the cult was detailed
far too dense and heavily researched to
be fake again she had the distinct
feeling that someone was trying to tip
her off about something the foundation
hadn't wanted to be widespread knowledge
with shaky hands she picked up the final
file what awaited her inside there was
only one way to find out she flipped it
open and began to read it was a file on
an entity known as scp-231 specifically
scp-231
1-7 an addendum was attached to the
beginning of the file reading all
Personnel assigned to
scp-231-7 must rotate out for one month
of psychological counseling after two
months on site
scp-231-7 is to be kept at an
undisclosed location all Personnel
assigned to scp-231 will be transported
there blindfolded from site 19 by a
route including no fewer than seven
different forms of transportation
including but not limited to aircraft
automobile underground tunnel and
several we cannot discuss here removal
of the blindfold during the transport
process is grounds for immediate
termination Personnel assigned to
scp-231-7 must undergo heavy
psychological testing before being
cleared to enter the site individuals
must score at least 72 points on the
Milgram obedience examination be
unmarried have no Offspring and express
nothing less than total loyalty to the
foundation normal psychological
screenings features against access to
disorders are waived so long as the
class D Personnel in question has the
mental capacity to carry out procedure
110 Montauk as needed Personnel who
Express sympathy towards
scp-231-7's plight and or Express a
desire to rescue or sympathize towards
scp-231-7 will be transferred to another
project without delay any actual rescue
attempts will be met with immediate
termination Personnel who have served on
the staff of
scp-231-7's containment team are not
required to divulge that information to
others no official record shall be kept
in the names of any staff assigned to
scp-231-7 nor will said service appear
in the Personnel files of said staff
while on site individuals assigned to
scp-231-7 will be issued concealing
helmets with integrated voice changers
to protect their identity on-site staff
are not to remove said uniforms in the
presence of other staff members off duty
hours are to be spent in private
quarters Alone six class D Personnel are
to be assigned to
scp-231-7 each month for the purposes of
carrying out procedure 110 Montauk
violent criminals are not to be used for
this purpose due to the possibility of
accidental fatality during the 110
Montauk process Dr Collingwood swallowed
the lump of dread in her throat her
Palms beginning to sweat
scp-231-7 was a young woman retrieved
during a police raid on a warehouse
owned by the children of the Scarlet
King she was one of seven women found
there the first of which went into labor
24 hours after being rescued she did not
give birth to an ordinary child however
she gave birth to a monster that took
the lives of dozens of civilians she did
not survive the birth the second woman
was lost shortly after also succumbing
to the dangers of the creature waiting
to be born from her womb one by one the
survivors the women chosen by this cult
to become the new bride of the Scarlet
King fell soon enough there was only one
left
scp-231-7 kept contained at a foundation
site in a hospital bed that she could
never leave Dr collingwood's stomach
churned as horrible images flooded her
mind the notes from attending
researchers in scp-231's file insisted
they were doing all they could to save
the woman to free her from her fate but
that there was little they could do each
birth opened a Gateway from this world
to another to a world of darkness and
despair and they could not allow the
final seal to be broken simply putting
the woman out of her misery would cause
the effect to jump to a new host a new
bride there was nothing to be done the
file fell from Dr collingwood's hand as
she pushed herself to her feet running
out into the hallway who put these on my
desk she shouted her voice echoing down
the empty Hall well what do you want
from me but no answer came slowly she
returned to her office and sank down
into her chair haunted by what she had
read she had seen horrific things in her
time at the foundation but nothing that
had shaken her to her core quite like
this the silence in Dr collingwood's
office was broken by the sound of a
tinny beep coming from her computer she
turned on the screen and saw the source
of the alert one new message from o5
command what could they possibly have to
say to her could it have something to do
with the files that had wound up on her
desk she accepted the message quickly
completed the mandatory multimodal
biometric ID scan and began to read
hello Dr Collingwood and congratulations
on your new appointment as
scp-9999's head researcher one of the
cushiest and most enviable assignments
in the entire Foundation
scp-999 is one of the few anomalies in
our custody who will not only never
attempt to harm you but will actively
try to save your life if you're ever in
danger though your initial reaction when
receiving this assignment was no doubt
Elation you may have thought it was odd
that such a seemingly low risk position
was assigned by the o5 council directly
if you had already heard rumors of this
prior to your assignment you probably
thought it was mere nepotism the o5s
protecting their friends and loved ones
by giving them the safest job possible
Dr Collingwood sat back in her chair
laughing to herself and shaking her head
she would never admit it but she
absolutely had heard those rumors even
believe them until it happened to her
unless you are so narcissistic to think
that someone on the o5 council must be
your secret admirer you've likely
realized that this is not the case to
understand why this is our concern you
need to know about
scp-9999's Origins you may have noticed
that its file makes no mention of where
it was discovered this is a deliberate
Mission if you are not familiar with the
mythology of the Scarlet King I suggest
you read up on him there's plenty of
unclassified information on him in the
foundation database all that's relevant
for now is that he is to the best of our
knowledge the most powerful malevolent
entity in the Multiverse her stomach
dropped At The Mention Of The Scarlet
King she was right this was all
connected somehow she leaned forward
eyes starting across the words with
increasing intensity as she read on
you've been with us since you were a
research assistant Dr Collingwood in
that time I assume you've heard many
rumors about some of the horrific things
we do here at the foundation that you've
probably never personally witnessed I
regret to inform you that these rumors
are true or at least they were a
pharmaturgical cult calling itself the
children of the Scarlet King enacted a
ritual wherein seven young girls became
Effigies for each of the Scarlet King's
Seven Brides allowing them to bear his
horrid Offspring how they obtain gain
the knowledge to perform this ritual is
unclear since all we ever recovered were
handwritten notebooks superficial
resemblances to some psychic practices
has led to some speculate that the
children of the Scarlet King may have
some ties to Modern soccer Cults it is
an interesting idea but no concrete
evidence has ever been found to link the
two investigation into the matter is
ongoing as for the ritual itself each
birth caused more destruction than the
last the writings of the cult's priest
predicted nothing less than the
apocalypse if the seventh bride gave
birth which could only be prevented if
procedure 110 Montauk was performed
without fail each and every day to our
seemingly great Fortune The Notebook
contained detailed instructions on how
110 Montauk was to be carried out
needless to say we found this
suspiciously convenient why would they
devise counter measures to prevent the
very apocalypse they were trying to
invoke we needed more in information
regarding these entities fortunately our
archaeologists have Unearthed numerous
tablets Scrolls and artifacts on the
ancient Davos they were a sadistic and
warmongering people who were granted
Unholy power and knowledge by the
Scarlet King as a result for the death
and suffering they caused one of the
David tablets in our possession found
covered in dust and blood was a theogony
for the Scarlet King and his Brides it
was quite informative the information
that we found most relevant to our
situation was that the seventh bride was
not like her sisters she was never
completely broken by her King's
subjugation instead of monsters she gave
birth to Great heroes in the hopes that
they would destroy her sister's children
and overthrow their father thus far all
have failed but by a vote of seven in
favor six against admittedly more out of
concern for procedure 110 montauk's lack
of viability as a long term containment
strategy than out of empathy for the
girl the o5 council decided to believe
that the seventh bride still remained
unbroken and that her child would be an
asset to us at the risk of causing an XK
Class end of the world scenario
scp-231-7 was relieved from procedure
110 Montauk following the deaths of
scp-231-1-6 and was allowed to give
birth
scp-999 was the result Dr Collingwood
gasped her hand flying to her mouth a
research assistant walking by her office
paused looked at her curiously through
the window she waved them off with a
forced smile and turned back to the
screen surely she couldn't have read
that correctly but no there it was plain
as can be go ahead and read that again
be sure you understand it in all its
Preposterous Ridiculousness the Tickle
Monster is the child of the Scarlet King
we've been running a
counter-intelligence campaign ever since
which is why everyone and their mother
thinks we've still got a girl strapped
to a rack in a bunker somewhere let them
think that far better for everyone that
the children of the Scarlet King believe
that they're playing us for fools than
for them to know that there is a threat
to their King the girl herself is fine
by the way she was cured of the trauma
from her ordeal buying scp-999 at which
point it was decided she could be
returned to her family so long as they
were all given class F amnestics
implanted with new identities and
relocated to a town at least one
thousand kilometers away from the
children of the Scarlet King's nearest
known activity on the insistence of the
Ethics Committee the family was also
given a seven-figure payout as
compensation for our repeated misdeeds
against their daughter as well as the
families of the other
scp-231s I suppose it was technically
malpractice on our part in case we have
any moles for the children of the
Scarlet King in the foundation as far as
anyone else knows 231-7's Family were
killed in front of her as part of 110
mom talk I'm sure you're skeptical are
we insane how could our sweet little
Tickle Monster ever hope to Dethrone a
lovecraftian horror of unparalleled
might well scp-999 is less than a decade
old it is still just a child and nowhere
near its full strength even so its power
is incredible even brief interaction
with scp-999 can permanently cure severe
depression and PTSD and more recent
experiments have resulted in the
complete Reformation of d-class
personnel who were previously
unrepentant sociopaths this effect is
not chemical but psychic and one day it
may grow powerful enough that not even
the Scarlet King himself will be immune
the experiment with scp-682 was most
remarkable based on multiple daveite
texts including descriptions from
scp-140 itself we are reasonably certain
that 6 82 is The Offspring of the fourth
Scarlet bride if this is true then
scp-999 is already strong enough to
temporarily quell the malevolence of its
own Eldritch siblings one day 999 could
very well be strong enough to
permanently reform its family members
just as it reforms human beings it will
not overthrow the Scarlet King by force
but with light and love and laughter
that can brighten the blackest of Hearts
999 is not in reality a safe class SCP
it is famul it is the best and really
the only weapon we have against some of
the most powerful hostile entities known
to exist by all means doctor enjoy the
relative safety of your new position but
do keep in mind that scp-999 is not a
mere pet that we fancy it is one of our
most valuable assets and must be
safeguarded at all costs its safety and
well-being are Paramount and you are not
at Liberty to share this information to
anyone without level 5 5 or 999 security
clearance as per protocol an authorized
disclosure of level 5 classified
information will result in your
termination this email will
automatically delete as soon as you
leave the terminal so feel free to
reread it as many times as necessary to
remember all the pertinent information
take good care of our little Tickle
Monster the fate of the Multiverse May
well depend on it your secret admirer if
anyone asks 05-1 Dr Collingwood let out
a long slow breath as her mind did its
best to process everything she just read
the message looked official and when she
really thought about it this all made a
twisted kind of sense what could scp-999
possibly be if not some sort of Mythic
hero of divine prophecy what other
explanation could there be for something
so utterly perfectly good maybe one day
that happy little orange slime would
save them all and do it with a smile but
for now it was just a little innocent
child no need to burden with talk of
heroism of epic battles between good and
evil for now she would just pour scp-999
a heaping bowl of M Ms give it a gentle
pet and say thank you the Tickle Monster
gurgled excitedly in response nuzzling
his new head researcher's hand he didn't
understand what she was thanking him for
but he appreciated it all the same
scp-106 is like something out of a night
terror that gray Rotting Flesh those
wide empty eyes like those of a shark
that Relentless corrosion and Decay that
follows him everywhere but what if I
told you that beneath that horrifying
exterior was a heartbreaking tragic
backstory some of our more eagle-eyed
viewers know that scp-106 has a wide
variety of potential origin stories
different events that may have led to
the old man we all know and fear today
so this is just one of several
hypothetical backstory with that little
caveat out of the way it's time to see
if we can bring a tear to your eye with
the tragic tale of
scp-106 back in the year 2000 Dr Robert
Scranton and his wife Dr Anna Lang were
head researchers at site 120. the two of
them shared a lot of things a home a
life a shared love of Bon Jovi songs but
one of the things they had in common was
a passion for experimental research the
two worked together to develop a device
called The Lang Scranton stabilizer
which was an early prototype of the
reality anchors used by the SCP
Foundation to this day during a round of
routine tests an earthquake unexpectedly
struck site-120 Dr Scranton was working
in reality lab a when the ground beneath
him began to rumble the LSS shook from
the activity components sliding out of
place or breaking off altogether by the
time the guards and Dr Lang arrived to
inspect the scene both Dr Scranton and
the LSS control panel were gone upon his
disappearance Dr Scranton was initially
presumed dead however five years 11
months and 21 days later his whereabouts
became clear on December 23 2005 the LSS
control panel reappeared in site 120's
reality lab a it was covered in unknown
organic matter and wreaked a vomit blood
and death as Dr Anna Lang wandered into
the area against the warnings of her
colleagues she was overwhelmed with
grief and horror she choked back tears
as she accessed the control panel
retrieving the audio files left there
and realized that Dr Scranton had been
keeping a log of his time in whatever
place the disaster had sent him the
husband she had lost had in a way come
back to her but she could not see him
she could hear his voice but where was
he there was so much blood so much
unidentified organic matter it looked
like some something had exploded onto
the control panel and she didn't want to
think about what or who that could have
been as Robert's wedding ring fell to
the floor Landing in the muck the
emotional strain became too much for Dr
Lang she collapsed onto the ground
hitting her head on the pavement Dr Lang
survived her fall left only with a
tender spot on her skull and a wealth of
questions she was almost too afraid to
answer but she had to find out with
answers at her fingertips she had to
know what had become of her dear Robert
so with the help of the other side 120
researchers who promised to step in when
it became too painful Dr Lang began to
go through the audio archives left
behind by her lost love in the years
since he had vanished for the first
eight days Dr Scranton didn't speak at
least not in any recognizable words he
hyperventilated he muttered to himself
he sobbed he screamed with pure rage and
despair but he didn't say any word he
paced around the new space clawing for a
way out throwing his shoulder against
any hard surface he could in an attempt
to burst open a door but he was trapped
on his 11th day in the pocket Dimension
outside of any world he knew Dr Scranton
began to speak he reminded himself
reminded anyone who might someday listen
who he was Robert Scranton age 39 born
September 19
1961. favorite color blue favorite song
Living on a Prayer wife Anna every day
he repeated these simple truths seeking
comfort in his memories of Anna and the
life they once shared her green eyes
their wedding day her dressed in white
shoving a piece of cake into his face
with a giddy laugh and a sparkle in her
eye he hoped that she was okay that she
had managed to escape the chaos with her
life but she had been spared a similar
fate he repeated her nickname the
password he had set for the control
panel Anna bobana at this point he
realized that the machine was still
recording he called out for help
desperate to see if anyone could hear
him is anyone there hello anyone anyone
but of course there was no answer why
the hell is this thing even working it
can't be working amused what the hell he
couldn't see anything not the switches
or the knobs only the blinking of the
red recording light he was growing
hungrier and thirstier by the day and
though he knew he should be dead from
dehydration by now somehow he wasn't he
was still alive soon he found the
controls and determined he had been
trapped in this place for two weeks
three days 47 hours and 58 minutes he
realized at this point that no matter
how hungry he got no matter how long he
went without water he would not die
somehow in this place his body kept
going his heart ticked along far past
what should have been his expiration
date he retrieved a small picture of
Anna from pocket gazing at her face by
The Faint glow of the red light two
months four days and three hours in he
recorded a formal message my name is
Robert Scranton I'm a former head
researcher of sight
120 a foundation facility dedicated to
studying various reality bending scps
for the purpose of developing more
advanced countermeasures towards such
threats for the last Red Light speak to
me two months eight days 16 hours uh
what the red light said I have been
trapped in what I believe to be an empty
pocket Dimension alone yeah alone all
alone I'm calling this place SCP
um I don't know I can't even remember
where we are screw it I don't know
what's happened in the past red light
please again two months eight days 16
hours but no one else is around to argue
and at this point I'm just talking into
this control panel to keep myself
together I I need to keep a record there
might be some poor chap in the future
who ends up like me and if this
eventually actually makes it out maybe
maybe I can help stop that from
happening that's all I have going for me
right now and I really need something to
go for
so yeah Robert Scranton documenting a
new SCP for future research purposes
that'll have to do here we go a few days
later he added to his informal SCP log I
don't know if we could contain wherever
I am it's definitely not on Earth to be
honest I don't know where it is I I
think it has something to do with the
stabilizer prototype I'll explain that
more later
um okay uh yeah wherever I am I don't
think it can be contained much as
created no no that's not the word
um entered yeah entered is better I came
into this place because of some really
bad reality bending accident no no
Robert don't be like that yet you don't
know if there's no exit yet uh
this place it's some sort of reality Gap
I think it's dark really dark as in this
little red light that shows my words are
actually being recorded is the only
visible light in this entire place I
can't even see my hands and I can barely
see the control panel here I've had to
basically use the light as a center and
remember how many steps I take and in
which direction I haven't gone past 100
yet I'm too too scared to I wonder if my
hair is turning white right now I can't
even see what color it is anymore
speaking of which my head has been a bit
itchy recently if I don't concentrate on
it it's fine but I feel this tingling
all over my face I'm not sure why I I
just discovered a new property of this
place all this time I've been thinking I
may be walking on some sort of flat
ground if you will I keep eye contact
with the little red light as far as I
could see and it seems I could walk in a
straight flat path Jesus my head is
buzzing right now I think the adrenaline
is still kicking but if if my hypothesis
is correct and this really is some sort
of reality void then there shouldn't be
anything to walk on now that I think
about it the whole time I've been here
it felt like I'm walking but also I'm uh
swimming through something it's like I'm
walking through really thick black gel
there's enough tension to keep me on a
Surface but find a imagine myself
pressing down hard enough I I can
descend wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait I I think I need to test this more
I'll be back two months 17 days two
hours navigation is largely affected by
conscious impulses to travel in a
certain direction so this definitely
isn't a complete reality Gap at least
according to mine and honest theories
if it were I wouldn't be able to move at
all since space wouldn't have existed
okay okay this makes a lot more sense
than it did before great great job
Robert okay you're getting there come to
think of it I should have realized that
sooner when I was able to move in a flat
plane to and from a little red it also
explains why I'm Not Dead from
dehydration or hunger yet time barely
passes in here okay yeah so I stood
right next to low red and went straight
down okay from here on out imagine
little red as the origin of a 3D space I
went um
down yeah right and then then I was able
to come back up to little red again I've
also been able to Fly Above red movement
in here is slow like I said gel analogy
but best I can describe it as Robert
became more and more familiar with his
surroundings with the truth of where he
found himself something became clear of
all the things in this new reality he
and his little red light were the
realest with time they would begin to
degrade to fall apart he had an
estimation three years before he would
be gone for good he had to try and look
for an end to this place a way out what
did he have to lose as it turned out
what he had to lose was himself he
couldn't feel his legs anymore couldn't
keep a grip on his own body he ran in
one straight line for six months but
found no Edge no end in sight he went
down for eight months straight and never
hit bottom his sole companion was the
little red light and he continued to
talk to it as if it ever answer his
hands began to phase into each other the
Integrity of his form beginning to fade
and warp no matter what happened to him
he could not die his sanity began to
crumble his voice breaking into
uncontrollable sobs and hysterical
laughter however Robert Scranton had
been he was gone he was something else
now and who knew how long that new thing
would last for the next 25 years Dr Anna
Lang tried her best to put the thought
of her lost husband out of her head it
almost worked some days she almost
forgot that hole in her heart then one
fateful day site 120 received a deadly
visitor
scp-106 reached through the back wall of
her lab dripping its horrible rot all
over the floor it grabbed for her its
touch melting her lab coat as she tore
away from its toothless grin the
singular focus and its milky eyes the
old man chased her down pushing past a
guard's bullets tearing through
everything in its path she had done
enough work on dimensional anomalies to
recognize one when she saw it and this
was one of the most destructive she had
ever encountered when it finally caught
her it said one word red then another
one that made her eyes fill with tears
Dr Robert Scranton had found a way to
escape the dead end prison he had fallen
into that gap between worlds all it had
taken was giving up his Humanity letting
that world rearrange his atoms and make
him something monstrous something that
destroyed all it touched he couldn't
remember why he needed to find Anna how
he had been separated from her for so
long he could only remember that he
wanted her wanted to be with her wanted
to touch her again even as she screamed
and melted in her hands
scp-106 was once a man just like any
other man what he is now shares that
vague shape of the human he used to be
the Vegas hints of his memories but that
is where the similarities end like the
Rotting Flesh of his body might suggest
he is little more than a shambling
corpse with a ravenous appetite for
violence Dr Robert Scranton is dead but
he will never rest anyone who holds more
than just a passing knowledge of the SCP
Foundation has likely heard the name of
one Dr Jack Bright Like A lot of the
other high-ranking staff his name
carries with it a reputation for
anomalous expertise far beyond many
working at the foundation having risen
through the ranks and achieved the
position of personnel director for site
17 19 and 63. Dr bright may just seem
like a highly competent and devoted
member of the organization but the
history of the man himself is one that
will likely forever be linked with
tragedy and Trauma Jack Bright's life
has been turbulent to say the least with
themes of rebirth and regeneration and
constantly following him and his family
and all the curses that those ideas
bring born to Adam and Evelyn pranked
Young Jack has sadly never experienced
what many would consider an ordinary
life you see both his parents were also
researchers within the SCP Foundation
meaning that since birth Jack Bright has
never known a life that wasn't linked
with the foundation and its many
anomalous happenings and it didn't stop
there either at some point Dr Adam
bright would rise through the ranks of
the foundation much like his son would
later come to do Adam progressed from
researcher to Personnel director to site
director and then eventually even to the
high station of o5 council member but
this career trajectory within the
foundation was cut short when Jack
Bright's father met an untimely end
assassinated on the orders of his fellow
o5 council members but why what could
have led to Young Jack suffering the
loss of his foundation-employed father
well it had to do with the other bright
children you see Jack was far from an
only child in fact he had a considerable
number of siblings while you might be
forgiven for thinking this would provide
a younger Jack Bright with equals
friends that he would at least endure
his anomalous adjacent childhood with
this was sadly not the case one of
Jack's Brothers TJ bright was born with
his very own anomalous abilities TJ had
something of a gift for healing
possessing the power to absorb the
injuries and illnesses of anyone around
him purely through physical touch but
the unfortunate side effect is that TJ
also takes on another person's ailments
himself experiencing their pain and
sickness so they don't have to if you're
Jack Bright it had to be hard to see
your younger brother suffering from
wounds and diseases passed on to him so
that others don't suffer but there's
still the lingering question what
happened to Jack and TJ's father Adam
what led to his assassinate nation and
what role did TJ play in the events
leading up to that untimely death while
like much of Dr Bright's family life it
began with a tragedy trying for another
baby Adam and Evelyn eventually had a
daughter giving jack TJ and their other
siblings a new sister however this was
sadly short-lived as the newest member
of the bright family was stillborn
bearing witness to the grief that would
have caused his parents was no doubt
hard on Jack but even more upsetting was
what came next naturally having both
studied anomalies within the SCP
Foundation Evelyn and Adam were willing
to Define death itself in order to get
their newborn daughter back and luckily
for them they had been presented with
the perfect anomaly to achieve this goal
in the form of their young son TJ and
his regenerative Powers however what
resulted was a creature that later
became known as
scp-321 while TJ was able to revive the
child child her body aged at a rapidly
accelerated rate she became devoid of
melanin in her hair eyes and skin still
able to vocalize but unable to
intelligibly speak
scp-321 is known to have spatial
awareness issues as well as a low level
of Intelligence on top of that scp-321
seems to have inherited some of her
brother TJ Bright's healing abilities
capable of regenerating any injury she
suffers at five times the normal speed
attributed to an overproduction of stem
cells it was also this that caused her
body to rapidly age and grow with no
signs of stopping taken in by the SCP
Foundation and given the designation
along with TJ who became known as
scp-590
scp-321 was separated from the rest of
the bright family Adam still a junior
researcher at the time pleaded with his
foundation superiors for his daughter to
be released back into the care of her
family every time he he made the request
it was denied it didn't seem to matter
how much higher up the managerial ladder
of the SCP Foundation Adam bright
climbed there always seemed to be a
message from above telling him no in
time he was appointed to the o5 council
it was then that Adam bright issued a
mandate for scp-321's immediate release
and the rest of the council didn't take
kindly to that trying to get his
daughter back cost Adam his life and
meant that young Jack Bright had lost
not only one of his brothers and a
sister but a father too Jack Bright
assisted the SCP Foundation with keeping
his brother TJ or scp-590 contained for
his own safety unlike his remaining
siblings Jack still seemed eager to
follow in the footsteps of his mom and
dad another of his sisters Claire Pierce
was angered by the foundation's actions
and how they had treated her family this
caused her to join up with the Serpent's
hand a group of interests with the goal
of 1 day exposing the SCP Foundation to
the world then there was mikhailbright
who had the opposite reaction to his
sister he devoted himself to the
foundation becoming one of their most
skilled and highly efficient field
operatives known to some as agent Cowboy
needless to say there remains plenty of
division between the bright siblings
something that would undoubtedly exact a
heavy toll on Jack who for his part
continued his family's Legacy by joining
the foundation as a junior researcher
this is where his life would once again
be altered forever to begin with Jack
seemed to have it easier than most
starting out at the SCP Foundation as
previously mentioned the bright name
already carried significant pull within
the organization not only allowing him
to get his foot through the proverbial
door but also giving jack a much needed
win after his past family troubles after
all he had a considerable amount of
emotional baggage and Trauma to deal
with so the up-and-coming junior
researcher perhaps deserve to Coast by
for a while although it wouldn't last
long and Jack Bright would be
irreversibly and irreparably changed on
one fateful day it was a seemingly
menial task a job that could have been
done by anyone else and things might
have turned out completely different if
they had but yet in giving it to a
certain Junior researcher who was in
good standing the foundation completely
reoriented the trajectory of Jack's life
he had been assigned to perform research
on scp-963 an ornate and rather
beautiful Amulet of Unknown Origin and
purpose the piece was constructed from
elegant white gold sporting an oval cut
ruby surrounded by 13 brilliant cut
diamonds in a starburst pattern it was a
truly Exquisite and well-crafted piece
of jewelry with a rather strange
property to it not yet realizing the
active anomalous effects of the amulet
Dr bright made the honest mistake of
touching scp-963 with his bare hands it
was purely an act of human error
avoidable and yet carrying consequences
that would last a lifetime or several
you see as it so happened the exact same
fateful day that Dr bright had made the
mistake of allowing scp-963 to make
contact with his skin another anomaly
had simultaneously managed to breach
containment
scp-076-2 better known as able The
Immortal Warrior tore his way through
the foundation pulling his bladed
Weaponry out of a pocket Dimension and
cutting down any Personnel in this path
as he continued his Rampage when the
slaughter was over the dust cleared and
able recontained Junior researcher Jack
Bright laid dead tragically slain during
the breach or so at first seemed it was
during the cleanup in the aftermath of
Abel's rampage that a member of d-class
personnel named Tom Higley was assigned
to dispose of the bodies left in the
wake of the undying Warriors Massacre
that was when Tom unknowingly picked up
the amulet that Dr bright had been
holding when he was killed instantly the
d-class suffered a peculiar change one
that would soon become a regular
Occurrence at the SCP Foundation Tom
Higley became Dr Jack Bright once again
like with his brother TJ's anomalous
powers and the tragedy of his stillborn
sister
scp-321 the theme of rebirth and
regeneration became a core part of
Jack's life he was alive once again and
inhabiting a new body now this might
seem like a positive development for the
aspiring Junior researcher but as Jack
Bright would soon learn the cost of
coming back from the dead was a hefty
toll to pay after the foundation had
established that the d-class now wearing
the amulet was indeed the person he
claimed to be they quickly discovered
that removing scp-963 from the wearer
would cause all higher brain function to
shut down immediately replacing the
amulet the body of Tom Higley was able
to move and speak once again albeit with
the voice and consciousness of Jack
Bright through his continued
experimentation with the artifact Dr
bright discovered that it acted as a
vessel for his Consciousness his
collected memories and his personality
they were all seemingly stored within
scp-963 and could be transferred into a
new body when the amulet was worn by
someone else however part of the high
cost of Jack's Newfound immortality was
the immediate loss of another person for
the sake of his continued life placing
the amulet on someone else would erase
everything about who they were
effectively killing them and wiping them
clean to make room for Jack himself it
was only thanks to his mistake of being
the last person to hold the amulet along
with being killed by Abel directly
afterwards that had now led to Jack
being unable to die of course the other
large part of the cost Jack had to pay
for living forever was that he
essentially now had to live as a pair
parasite passed on from host to host at
a regular rate he learned that after 30
days of sustained continuous contact
with scp-963 Jack's Consciousness could
become permanently affixed to a new body
if the amulet was removed after this
occurred then Bright's Consciousness
could still be passed on to a new body
meaning that he could in theory at least
create multiple copies of himself by
transferring into new host bodies via
the amulet and allowing them to wear it
for 30 days at a time to make the change
permanent naturally as they so often
tend to do the SCP Foundation imposed
sanctions and restrictions to prevent
the scenario from unfolding executing
any hosts wearing the amulet before they
could reach the 30-day permanent
transfer threshold afterwards scp-963
and Dr Bright's Consciousness would be
passed on to a new host and the cycle
would continue however after witnessing
The Immortal researchers continued
dedication to their cause the foundation
eventually relaxed its rules for Dr
bright Jack then went on to continue to
work with the foundation Rising through
the ranks and achieving promotions to
higher stations eventually becoming one
of the most well-known researchers of
scps to ever live but all the while he
did further examination of scp-963 you
might be fooled into thinking that
immortality would be a good but to Jack
Bright it is a never-ending curse moving
from host to host only surviving because
of a simple mistake that changed his
circumstances in ways he could never
have foreseen Dr bright lives in
frustration and longs to be free from
what he views as a curse of eternal life
he is perpetually aware that he'll
outlive everyone at the foundation have
to watch countless people die while he
lives on just like he had to live on
after the death of his father this curse
of immortality has led Dr Wright too
long for a permanent death ironically he
only became a part of scp-963 in a
moment of trying not to die and now
can't at all making the story of Dr Jack
Bright a truly saddening tale as history
often teaches us sometimes human beings
are the biggest monsters of all of
course when you join the ranks of the
SCP Foundation that starts to seem even
less likely and why wouldn't it after
all just look at some of the creatures
they encounter and keep in containment a
giant unkillable lizard a being with
toothy protrusions growing out of its
body a whole host of immortal Eldritch
beings that could destroy reality and
one sadistic old man who drags
unsuspecting victims into his own
personal hellscape monsters are a dime a
dozen to the foundation Humanity could
never be anywhere near as evil or as
cruel as the real monsters even on their
worst day or at least you'd think
researcher Council had held much of the
same mentality that the SCP Foundation
had the job of Defending Humanity from
the real monsters of the world and it
was because of that belief that he had
never previously questioned the
containment procedures in place for
scp-1000 these beings were a species of
nocturnal and omnivorous Apes usually
with bodies covered in either gray brown
black red or white fur possessing the
same level of intelligence as the common
chimp the scp-1000s had been
colloquially described as a species
known as Bigfoot linking them to the
urban legend about an ape-like being of
dubious existence Kelton had hardly been
surprised that Bigfoot itself was an
anomalous SCP there were already a
number of others that the foundation had
encountered that seemed to have
influenced popular folklore from
different parts of the world in fact it
was that unique subcategory of anomaly
that Kelson was conducting Research into
when he came across the scp-1000 files
he was trying to determine in various
cases which came first the anomaly or
the legend did the existence of
scp-1000s inspire earlier human
civilizations to pass on stories of the
Sasquatch or at those Word of Mouth
Tales been somehow linked to the very
origins of scp-1000 themselves studying
the files celtsin knew there was a
memetic disease infecting hominids like
scp-1000 the infection meant that anyone
who observed one of the Bigfoot
creatures had at minimum a two percent
chance of suffering instantaneous brain
death it would make discovering the link
between the Sasquatch Legend and
scp-1000 difficult not being able to
directly look at the Apes but Kelton
hoped he wouldn't need to actually
observe the creatures only find evidence
that proved which predated witch
scp-1000 or the legend of Bigfoot the
population of scp-1000 was limited
although their highest concentrations
were known to be found in the Pacific
Northwest region of North America as
well as in the Himalayan Mountain range
in Asia being stationed at a foundation
facility in the U.S researcher Kelson
opted to mount an expedition to the
former location a few odd occurrences
had taken place leading up to his
departure his car tires had been slashed
and now needed repairing newspaper
clippings were also left on kelson's
desk that told the various hikers to
deaths taking place in the Pacific
Northwest a more paranoid person might
interpret these as subtle indirect
threats it certainly seemed as if
someone in the SCP Foundation wasn't
keen on Kelson departing for his
research trip nevertheless he changed
tact and called in sick to work sneaking
away to a small airstrip and boarding a
light cargo plane that smuggled him
towards the forests of North America
once he had arrived Knight was already
falling Kelson was on his own traversing
the woods as the sun rapidly receded out
of view behind the tree line leaving the
forest in darkness save for the beam
from his flashlight the researcher was
hardly an outdoorsy type and far from an
expert at exploring the Wilderness but
he pushed on Into the Heart of the woods
to the areas where the most sightings of
scp-1000 had been reported it wasn't
long before the Torchlight fell over
something imprinted in the Woodland
floor a large footprint left by
something bipedal and rather similar to
an ape venturing further the sound of
Twigs breaking caused celtsin to whirl
around the noise had come from nearby
making it louder than the low background
Ambience of the forest at night he swung
his flashlight in the direction he
thought it had come
only seeing the shadows of branches cast
against the tree trunks then another
noise leaves rustling as something
passed by followed by more snapping of
Twigs than the shaking of the leaves
again this thing whatever it might have
been was encircling him frantically
Kelton tried to spot it with his light
when suddenly the beam fell over
something tall a hulking figure moving
between the trees even from that
split-second sighting it was clearly an
instance of scp-1000 the momentary
Glimpse had reminded the Intrepid
researcher of an important detail he
couldn't look at them a two percent
chance of instant brain death seemed too
low to worry about but kelton's research
had described the effects of the mometic
disease to be cumulative the longer an
scp-1008 was observed the higher the
chance of being killed on the spot by
the infection snapping his eyes shut as
tight as he could Kelton was frozen to
the spot at the mercy of the sound
surrounding him the s 1000 was drawing
closer enough for the researcher to
detect its footsteps his pulse quickened
along with his breathing to match
although he was already aware that the
Apes weren't known for being aggressive
hearing its heavy breathing as it drew
nearer was enough to make him uncertain
Kelton wasn't sure if the Bigfoot would
attack him or pass him by but by far the
last thing he had expected was to hear
it start speaking you man came a deep
gravelly voice it was the kind of sound
an animal makes that can almost be
mistaken for speech Kelton wasn't fully
convinced it had been a word rather just
his ears Playing Tricks on him in a
moment of heightened fear human he
repeated much clearer there was no
mistaking it a second time the scp-1000
had spoken
yeah you can talk Kelton exclaimed in
disbelief the Sasquatch didn't answer
directly instead the researcher detected
the sound of receding footsteps there
was a pause as the scp-1008 turned back
to Kelton follow human it said open your
eyes and follow me what what about the
disease Kelton shouted keeping his
eyelid still screwed shut the ugly safe
the ape replied before it resumed
walking away cautiously opening his eyes
and lifting his flashlight Kelton could
see the hairy figure making its way
through the forest its back turned to
him he could see it the researcher could
look directly at it and yet nothing
seemed to be happening no adverse side
effects no instant brain death the odds
were low Kelton reminded himself as he
began to warily follow the path of the
ape following at a distance he made sure
to momentarily glance away trying not to
stare for too long at the scp-1000
creature in the hope that might disrupt
the memetic effect of the infection
before long they had arrived at a cave
deep in the heart of the forest The
Embers of a small fire were still a glow
near the rocky entrance as they lumbered
inside the scp-1000 threw extra wood on
the fire poking it with a long stick
until the Flames began to reach higher
the flickering orange gave Kelton a
better look at the ape its large frame
covered almost head to toe in brown fur
there was also something about the
creature that seemed off not unsettling
but almost sad melancholic like it was
lonely the researcher had been so amazed
that he could observe the creature for
so long without dying that he barely
focused in on the more important
Discovery
scp-1000s were far more intelligent than
the foundation files had indicated
capable of not only speech but emotion
too do you have a name Kelton stammert
unsure where to start
it replied that you my name yeah you'll
have to forgive me I'm a little taken
aback by all this the researcher hastily
explained yeah you're able to articulate
your species is it Advanced enough to
have names why should that be surprising
gricor asked oh well it's just the
foundation seems to think you and your
kind are I don't mean any offense but
mindless beasts the ape made a huffing
exhaling sound Kelson noticed after a
moment that they were chuckling a dry
almost sarcastic chuckle it was unlike
anything he had expected to learn about
scp-1000 that reminded him of why he'd
come here
um right core uh may I ask something he
cleared his throat nodding the scp-1000
instance poked at the fire again paying
little mind to the human in its company
where did you and your people come from
Kelton asked what's your history why
ricor replied abruptly uh you see humans
have these Legends stories about
something called Bigfoot or Sasquatch
Foundation that humans I work with they
call you one in the same I wanted to
know if that was true for a short moment
the creature paused then Gregor began to
give Kelton the truth the real truth and
as they spoke it was as if the
researcher could see the story unfolding
emphasized by the pain in the Apes teary
eyes we were like you long long ago it
began explaining we in humans we evolve
together side by side for a time there
was peace between us but we began to
grow faster stronger became smarter
while you were left behind you evolved
before early humans did Kelton probed
indeed cracker answered with a gentle
nod we began to surpass the humans you
were still young still hunting and
foraging for food while we were moving
far beyond thousands and thousands of
years were able to develop our culture
our technology all before the humans had
even come close to Fire and the wheel
but that doesn't make any sense the
researcher interjected yet again if that
was the case mankind would have never
had its chance to reach the top of the
food chain we would have died out and
that would have made you the dominant
species on the planet we were yes
scp-1008 replied for a time what
happened Gregor turned with a solemn
look on their face you it replied
plainly humans happened we covered the
world billions and billions of us you
were rare as few as we are now my people
made technology far beyond anything
humans have dreamed of either before or
since trains ships Vehicles created from
the trees and the Animals communication
using parts of insects and smaller
creatures cities filled with us where we
lived in harmony stretched out across
parts of world humans dared not tread
organic technology Kelton gassed
fascinating we had weapons too and that
was our biggest mistake what kind of
weapons the researcher quizzed the ape
given how advanced you were compared to
humanity at that time I'm assuming your
Weaponry was far beyond our early Spears
and clubs the devastating mind Gregor
said staring ahead Into the Fire almost
if the dancing Flames conjured up images
of the kind of Destruction his ancestors
weapons could cause I think I understand
Kelton said there was some kind of
conflict yes a majority of your people
perish oh my condolences that that would
have removed you from the top of the
evolutionary chain and allowed the
earliest ancestors of humanity to usurp
your place there was the disease you and
your species carry a result of the war a
sort of lingering radioactive fallout
but on a genetic level we are not sick
gricor ground your people lied they made
that up and there was no war it was a
Slaughter Kelton felt quiet unsure of
what to say humans would stay away from
us back then we avoided them too you
slept during the night when we were
awake but you made a deal a deal was
something ancient and dangerous in the
forests a deal to even the score you
found our weapons and didn't hesitate no
that that's
the foundation researcher tried to
protest the look of sadness on the Apes
face stopped his sentence before he
could finish we were almost entirely
wiped out in a single day humans
switched places with us we became less
and they became more they used our
technology to forget about us wiped our
memories so they wouldn't have to face
up what they had done but we will never
forget and the foundation they maintain
a facade Kelton realized that's why they
tell us you're infected that if we look
at you we'll die they're ashamed
we all should be not just ashamed
greiker replied afraid they fear we want
revenge retribution for what was done to
our people and do you the ape took
another pause as if it was pondering or
just allowing itself a moment to feel
sad we have forgiven you that answered
I'm not sure we deserve that Kelton said
back as the pair Sat by the fire until
the sun came up it's rare for the SCP
Foundation to encounter an anomaly that
volunteers information about itself that
seems to actively desire to be studied
to be investigated to be known but
scp-082 is one such anomaly
scp-082 calls himself Ferdinand a giant
man with an even bigger appetite and
though he is cheerful and chatty even
friendly by a CP foundation's standards
it can be difficult to sort the fact
from the fiction where his life story is
concerned at various points in his
containment he has claimed to be a
vampire a homunculus Sherlock Holmes
Alexander the Great Dr Frankenstein and
his monster Napoleon and Big Bird to
name a few but on October 27 2016
Ferdinand made a particular unusual
request he asked for a set of poetry
books a stack of blank paper and a quill
he isolated himself for days refusing to
eat drink or sleep as he wrote page
after page when he was finished he had
written a poem that seemed to be the
first honest exploration of his life
story since he was first contained by
the foundation it can be difficult to
determine when scp-082 is lying since he
is always grinning widely and claims to
only lie when it is through his teeth
but after reading the aforementioned
poem aloud he wept openly in what seemed
to be a genuine display of emotion
according to the events described in the
poem which should be taken with a small
grain of salt this is what ferdinand's
life was like before he became
scp-082 Ferdinand could not remember his
earliest years what his parents or his
childhood home might have looked like
his earliest memory was of a makeshift
home in an Alleyway a box to sleep in
and a bundle of rags serving as a
makeshift bed for food he would steal
the old bread thrown out by a nearby
Bakery and catch birds and rats that
were slow enough for him to grab even as
a young boy he was enormous three times
the size of other boys his age his
strength and stature made him appealing
to the workhouses at first but they
always ended up throwing him out calling
him a monster the monster after the
third workhouse chased him into the
streets with whips he resigned himself
to a solitary life in the shadows down
the abandoned Alleyways were not even
the Beggars would go so overrun were
they with rats and filth it was better
for Fernando
no one would try to mock him to hurt him
to dispose of the monster once and for
all he spent his days and nights there
in the little Alleyway he had turned
into a home keeping as quiet as possible
out of fear that he would be discovered
by someone with ill intentions one night
he got his hands on a row of meat Tarts
left on a windowsill and ate to his
heart's content he slept unusually
soundly that night with a full belly for
the first time in a long time and
without knowing it he must have begun to
snore as the first soft beams of
sunlight fell across his face stirring
him from Sleek he heard the sound of a
strange man's voice perhaps it was
someone just passing by on a nearby
street but no there was a shadow at the
end of the alleyway blocking out some of
the light he retreated out of sight
helping to avoid detection but he could
see two more blurry figures stepping
into his vision all of a sudden they
started running towards him at top speed
this was no accidental encounter they
had spotted him and were targeting him
specifically for what he didn't want to
find out the giant boy climbed to his
feet and tried to run but the alley was
narrow and the three men grabbed hold of
each of his arms while one grabbed his
legs and forced him to the ground
someone stuffed a dirty rag into his
mouth muffling his cries for help and
out of the corner of his eye he saw the
glint of a metal pipe swinging at his
head then everything went dark when
Fernand opened his eyes again all he
could see was red Vivid red on all sides
as his vision adjusted he realized he
could see metal bars as well the red was
fabric red cloth draped over the iron
cage that now held him prisoner he
stumbled to his feet forced to stoop to
avoid bumping his head on the top of the
cage and rattled the bars desperately
out please he begged though he felt as
though it was useless his plea was not
met with silence however but with loud
cheerful music he covered his ears at
the sudden noise jumping back but it
came from all sides and there was no
Escape suddenly his eyes were blinded by
a sudden bright light as the red cloth
was yanked from the cage in one swoop it
took a moment for his eyes to adjust but
as he blinked the tears from his eyes
Ferdinand could make out a man with a
large mustache a long red and gold coat
a matching top hat and a gold-tipped
cane the man grinned at him but it was
not a friendly face the smile did not
reach his eyes which glinted with a cold
cruel Delight behind the ringmaster
Ferdinand could now see a crowd sitting
men women and children all watching him
with rapturous Fascination a mix of
intrigue disgust and horror on their
faces he looked from face to face
seeking any kindness any sympathy but
found not one who looked as if they
might help him escape the music climbed
to a crescendo and when it stopped the
ringmaster spoke ladies and gentlemen
boys
I have brought you something the likes
of which no one has ever seen before I
have traveled the world in search of
oddities and Curiosities to delight and
shock you with and after Crossing every
ocean exploring the furthest reaches of
the globe I have brought you a very
special gift do not be afraid the Beast
will not harm you I will ensure that you
are all perfectly safe should he try
anything at all one of my helpers here
he gestured to one of two large men
standing on either side of the cage each
brandishing an ax
Fernand recoiled at the threat but there
was nowhere for him to go in the cramped
cage already a bit too small for his
massive body the ringmaster continued
his speech pacing back and forth in
front of the cage and running his Cane
across the bars with a horrible
clattering sound
as you can see this creature looks like
a boy but his statue reveals the truth
it is something else entirely something
bigger stronger more vicious than any
child could ever be you see the legs
like great tree trunks the arms strong
enough to wrestle a bear but do not dear
audience neglect to notice its Mighty
Jaws like steel strong enough to crush
anything it bites down on strong enough
to crack through bone and the teeth
enormous and pearly white with a smile
bright enough to light up the darkness
what do you say Beast will you give the
people a smile Fernand coward in the
cage watching everything with wide
frightened eyes he certainly did not
feel like smiling when he did not budge
the ringmaster whacked his Cane against
the bars making another horrible
metallic clang well these people paid
good money to be here to not keep them
waiting after another moment of silence
and Fernand remains stocks still the
audience began to Boom tossing empty
popcorn bags and insults at the cage the
ringmaster leaned in close and whispered
smile for the people or I'll see to it
you suffer Agony you could only dream of
this threat snapped Ferdinand out of his
Frozen Terror and standing as tall as he
could in the little cage he smiled wide
showing all of his many many teeth at
once the audience erupt into cheers at
the site and the band played triumphant
horns as the ringmaster basked in the
Applause
about that the ringmaster took off his
hat and bowed low to the ground holding
out his hat for the audience to toss in
coins in a token of their appreciation
for an excellent show by the time the
applause was finished his hat was filled
with shiny silver and gold he tossed the
Hat now heavy with New Wealth to one of
the guards and pulled a gold-handled
whip from his pocket
I cracked the whip ominously then turned
toward the cage he cracked the whip
again this time across ferdinand's back
the boy roared in pain a great bellowing
sound that carried for miles around and
he fell to his knees the sound was so
loud so powerful that the audience was
terrified small children began to cry
and people poured from the circus tent
in a panic afraid the Beast would break
free and tear them apart but there was
no Beast only a frightened boy who did
not understand his own strength crying
at the cruelty the world had shown him
all his life once they were alone the
ringmaster turned to Ferdinand again
catching his eye stop your crying boy
Romero now you'll be coming with me
together we're going to be very very
rich and I will make you a star whether
you want to be one or not and for a time
that became fernand's life night after
night crammed into a cage fed on chicken
bones and leftover scraps paraded in
front of an uncaring audiences as the
ringmaster tormented him showing him off
as a sideshow attraction and forcing him
to smile with the threat of the ax or
the whip his fellow circus folk were not
much Kinder than the ring Master either
the clown sprayed him with water and
taunted him through the bars the animal
trainers threatened to pit him against
their lions and see who came out alive
only one person ever showed Ferdinand an
ounce of kindness at the circus a
bearded lady who would sing opera songs
in a beautiful clear soprano her voice
was the loveliest thing Ferdinand had
ever heard a tiny Slice of Heaven in the
hell his life had become days LED
together as the tour went on a stretch
of seemingly endless days and nights
until the day of the last show came he
looked up at the thin slivers of night
sky visible through the gaps in the tent
the twinkling of stars just Out Of Reach
what would become of him after the tour
ended what Horrors awaited him next
would he just sit there and take it or
would he finally do something to bring
it all into a close he flexed his
muscles quietly taking notice of how he
had grown over the past few months
regular feedings more than he had gotten
on the street had bulked him up
considerably he now stood at over seven
feet tall and could feel that his
strength had doubled or even tripled the
show began as it usually did with the
crack of the ringmaster's whip but
suddenly the man stepped forward and
began a speech he had never made before
great Beast
peace hunger behold as I set it free and
to Ferdinand shock the ringmaster
unlocked the door to the cage and swung
it open he took a tentative step out
standing at his full height for the
first time in months as he stretched his
spine straight see
jab fernan's ribs with his Cane hard
enough to leave a dark purple bruise you
heard me smile while the whip cracked
again and the audience began to boo and
jeer throwing their garbage at Fernand a
bag hit his cheek with a slap and a deep
dark rage finally awoke beneath the
months of Terror you remember our
agreement do as I say or I shall cut off
something you'll miss before the
ringmaster could say another word
Ferdinand grabbed him and pulled him
into a bone-crushing embrace the man's
voice came out in a squeak peace what
are you doing next is not my name
Ferdinand bellowed and he opened his
mouth wide wider than he ever had before
and gobbled up the ringmaster in three
quick bites the audience screamed
fleeing from their seats but Ferdinand
moved faster than they did he grabbed
person after person starting with those
that had been the cruelest and shouted
the most insulting things and devoured
them one by one when he was full he ran
into the night into the forest and did
not stop until he was free he bathed in
the river washing away all that he had
done and remained there for quite some
time feeding on passerbys when his
hunger got the better of him his sense
of time grew fuzzy then and he could not
be sure how long he spent there the word
of missing townspeople eventually
reached a special organization one
dedicated to studying those like him and
for the second time in his life
Ferdinand was taken into custody by
strangers however these scientists were
much kinder to him and never called him
a beast they simply gave him a number
scp-082 Dr trebuchet side his wrath
fogging up the visor of his hazmat suit
he did a last-minute spot check making
sure he had his clipboard and Pen then
he reached for the shoebox feeling its
little occupant moving around as he
lifted it up the doctor turned as his
newly appointed assistant researcher
watchal barreled into the room the
researcher was late trebuchet couldn't
even imagine ever being tardy to his
first assignment but the foundation were
insistent on training up their new
recruits as quickly as possible exposure
to a mostly harmless anomaly would in
theory help to normalize some of these
stranger scps that the organization
dealt with Dr trebuchet held back a
cheap shot about watchel being so late
as the assistant researcher hurriedly
clattered into his own hazmat suit both
ready they stepped through the
decontamination airlock after it had
hissed loudly sterilizing the air and
the outer layers of their suits then the
two researchers continued into the
containment unit even with their hazmat
suits on the differences in temperature
and humidity were instantly noticeable
like the feeling you get stepping off a
plane after a long-haul flight the
cylindrical glass enclosure had been
perfectly climate controlled filled with
Wetland soil and stagnant water it was
like stepping inside a terrarium a tiny
little little pocket of swamp large
enough for someone well something to
comfortably live inside that something
was scp-811 sometimes known colloquially
by her nickname of the swamp woman
however since bringing her into
containment scp-811 had given herself a
different name which Dr trebuchet used
when addressing the slimy creature a he
greeted causing scp-811 to turn and face
the para Foundation Personnel
she hissed she had shown the capacity
for communication but possessed a
limited vocabulary and struggled with
the proper pronunciation of words Dr
trebuchet clarified he was there to ask
scp-811 questions to which she quickly
responded with a request for food
opening up the shoebox a frog hopped out
which the swamp woman quickly stomped on
and began to eat the dead creature
although while she possessed a mouth she
didn't exactly eat in the sense that we
understand it her body secretes the
slimy mucus that upon contact causes a
rapid rate of decomposition much like a
fly scp-811 will vomit onto things in
order to break them down so she can
digest their nutrients through
absorption she uses this ability both to
hunt and as a defensive countermeasure
against attackers spitting out the waste
of her food that collects in her stomach
grinning at her own efforts scp-811
finished her meal and indicated she was
ready to continue with questioning Dr
trebuchet handed his clipboard to
researcher watchel so that he could
conduct the interview as part of his
on-the-job training what is the earliest
thing you can remember watch last
reading from the board air we is theme
scp-811 echoed conveying that she didn't
fully understand watcho stammered Unsure
how to rephrase early things Dr
trebuchet interjected things before
before box I seem to be understanding
indicating her contain chamber before
before box trebuchet confirmed appearing
thoughtful for a moment scp-811 asked
most before Dr trebuchet nodded
vigorously telling her yes even though
the foundation had mandated this
interview he genuinely wanted to know
how she had become like this immediately
scp-811 gave sweeping demonstrative
gestures with her hands and described in
very vague levels of detail a man a man
who had been taller than a herself at a
time when she was also much much smaller
was like man she said pointing at her
own arm what was like him Dr trebuchet
probed trying to clarify what she meant
in response a pinched her modeled green
skin it surfaced slick with mucus this
not like a like men like people she
insisted her skin she meant her skin had
used to look human upon hearing the word
skin from the doctor scp-81 11 repeated
it prodding at her arm and then smiled
she'd learned a new word when questioned
further by Dr trebuchet while watchful
felt increasingly uneasy nearby the
swamp woman pointed to the inside of her
elbow she described what she had
experienced after this tall man had
approached her pain stick here cold a
said needle a Dr trebuchet encouraged
her to use the right word certain she
meant she had been injected with
something they're called needles needle
here scp-811 tried to mimic the sounds
of the word before then going on to
explain that she had experienced intense
pain soon after with her hands she
started miming that something had come
out of her mouth red red red was very
hungry he ate man skin like this hearing
her describe even in loose broken
terminology what had happened to her
became too much for assistant researcher
watchful as far as both he and Dr
trebuchet understood what a was telling
them she had been injected with
something while still a child and then
had eaten the person responsible Machel
who had children of his own couldn't
help but imagine the same horrible act
happening to his own kids and the
thought of it made him vomit in his
hazmat suit given her own chosen method
of attacking and dissolving prey scp-811
couldn't help that she interpreted
seeing watcho throwing up as an act of
hostility it alarmed the swamp woman
causing her to hardly Retreat to a
nearby pool of stagnant water within her
containment chamber refusing to
re-emerge until wachel and Dr trebuchet
had left angered by the assistant
researcher's lack of professionalism and
how it had interrupted the most coherent
explanation of scp-811's past Dr
trebuchet filed a dissatisfied note with
the SCP Foundation it read as follows
while I understand the appeal of
training the new blood on something
relatively harmless and as green as they
are could you please throw them at some
other humanoid for a while trying to
actually get things done done here had
watch will been able to stomach what he
had heard at scp-811 saying and probably
through more extensive interviews with
the creature trebuchet could have
learned the full extent of how the swamp
woman had come to be she had been able
to give the broad Strokes of it of
course but her descriptive ability was
limited the story had definitely fit
with what the foundation already assumed
to be the case that at some point a had
been human but what they hadn't been
aware of was the actions of this unknown
individual a nameless man or what he had
injected the young girl with in order to
trigger her transformation at any rate
the only explanation the foundation had
was the word of scp-811 herself who was
vague at best at worst it might not even
have been recalled with any degree of
accuracy she could have been lying if
she had the capacity to lie and the
specifics of who she was before why
someone had injected her and what with
were all still a complete mystery to the
foundation and not just to them either
given her partial comprehension scp-811
had long been suspected to have grown up
as a feral child a youngster abandoned
when there were only a few years of age
rather than as an infant it certainly
seemed to explain her limited
understanding of human language the fact
that she could communicate at all
implied that she had at some point lived
among other humans but hadn't fully
developed before her transformation but
even if she had been able to communicate
at an adult level scp-811 still wouldn't
have given the full story to Dr
trebuchet not because she was keeping
things from him but because she simply
couldn't the trauma of growing up alone
in the swamp being turned into a monster
and everything else that had come before
were all too much for her she had at
some point suffered a mental break her
mind shutting off the full details of
her past as a defense mechanism the
swamp woman had been through far more
and far worse than even she could
remember and announced to the girl who
would later come to call herself a the
SCP Foundation had been involved it had
all started way back a long time ago and
many many miles away from where it would
eventually lead to the birth of the
swamp woman specifically it began in
Siberia the SCP Foundation had learned
of an infectious skin disease that had
been discovered there by the gru
division P the Russian government's own
anomaly containment organization they
had encountered a virus that was highly
contagious and that would spread on
Direct contact with organic matter the
bad was far from the extent of it this
infection would begin to transform its
host turning them into a horrific fleshy
mutation that would attack any
non-infected life form in an aggressive
attempt to spread the virus further the
foundation called it as cp610 although
the grup troops had a different name for
it roughly translated they called it the
flesh that hates now was only through a
combined effort between the SCP
foundation and their Russian
counterparts in Gru division P that this
disease was contained to a single
isolated area within Siberia where it
had first been discovered the Russian
government at the time had agreed to
keep the area under their watchful eye
and that anyone who became infected by
scp-610 would be killed immediately of
course nobody had accounted for the one
who would get away a Russian operative a
researcher within grup had become
obsessed with scp-610 since its
Discovery the virus itself was horrific
producing abominable nightmares but it
could transform human physiology in mere
moments producing fleshy creatures that
were almost unrecognizable as people
this scientist began to wonder if this
transformative property of the virus
could somehow be controlled programmed
even then it may well hold the key to
some of the greatest breakthroughs in
medical science he envisioned using it
to grow replacement limbs out of tissue
cells or to trigger the reconstructive
regeneration of bodily damage the
scientists just needed to figure out how
to prevent scp-610 from fully
transforming someone the only problem
was anyone infected with it was killed
so he took it upon himself to sneak into
the isolated area in Siberia where he
could steal a sample of scp-610 from the
body of a recently terminated mutation
and he nearly made it away unscathed the
scientists plans were quickly discovered
by the joint effort between the SCP
Foundation and grup he had been
requesting a sample through the official
channels for months and now he had taken
one to experiment with and gone on the
run with a new identity calling himself
Alec Holland the scientist fled the
foundation Russian agent sent to pursue
him as far as he knew they were trying
to prevent him from carrying out what he
viewed to be a noble Endeavor but the
foundation knew that even if that tiny
sample of scp-610 was able to spread it
could cause a worldwide catastrophe
whilst piloting a small Lane Alec was
shot down over the swamplands of
Louisiana by the time Foundation
operatives arrived in the area all they
found was a burning rack little did they
realize Alec had been rescued by locals
who had taken him aboard their fan boat
and rushed him to hospital he would
later leave before his injuries had
fully healed and returned to the side of
the crash to discover something curious
his sample of scp-610 had been
cross-contaminated with the swamp's
stagnant water teeming with algae and
who knows what else Alec was running out
of time he knew that if his wounds
didn't kill him he would soon be
discovered by the foundation and grup
using a syringe he gathered up the
combination of the virus sample that had
mixed with the natural properties of the
swamp there was no way of knowing what
it would do whether it would still
mutate a person or whether the disease's
transformative effect had been altered
but he had to know and he was living on
borrowed time desperate he raced to the
nearest town a tiny community near the
swamp Alec told himself that the first
person he encountered would be his test
subject he had to see what effect this
altered version of the virus would do to
a human being it just so happened that
the first person he encountered was a
little girl named a and he wouldn't live
long enough to see the full extent of
what he was about to turn her into now
go check out SCP-173 origin story how
SCP-173 got to site 19 and scp-053 young
girl for more mysterious anomalies